río de janeiro está vacía y se enfrenta
a la escasez no hay turistas los hoteles
operan a media marcha y el color del
carnaval se esconde bajo el gris asfalto
de las calles este año la pandemia mató
al carnaval de río
la fiesta más icónica de brasil y dejó
sin sustento a miles de cariocas que
viven del espectáculo
no habrá carnaval este año es duro y
triste pero no habrá carnaval pido a la
gente que quisiera asistir a fiestas o
bailes de carnaval no está permitido ni
es legal no piensen que es parte de la
conversación porque estas celebraciones
no ocurrirán no volverán a las escuelas
de samba alma corazón y vida del
carnaval han tenido que reducir
drásticamente su personal a ellos se
suman infinidad de músicos y bailarines
así como comerciantes artesanos
diseñadores carpinteros soldadores
costureros y mecánicos muchos se quedan
si trabajo como escritor
voy a ver los desfiles de viradouro y a
disfrutar en casa no a intentar predecir
el futuro tendré 10 meses de trabajo y
lucharé por el campeonato porque la
escuela tendrá un año maravilloso y
llevaremos esa energía al futuro
y las consecuencias económicas de la
cancelación del carnaval para evitar una
mayor propagación del cob y 19 se
predicen nefastas con pérdidas estimadas
por la patronal de los comerciantes en
509 millones de dólares el año pasado
2,1 millones de turistas de los cuales
cerca de 500.000 eran extranjeros
visitaron río durante la fiesta y
dejaron unos 717 millones de dólares en
tierra carioca